>>> AND YOUR TOTAL WAS $208.45.
>> SORRY, DID YOU SAY 208?
>> AND 45 CENTS, YES.
>> THE SIGN SAID IT WAS HALF
OFF.
>> NOT THIS SHIRT.
JUST THE STUFF IN THAT SECTION.
>> OH, IT WAS IN THAT SECTION.
>> OH, THEN THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
SOMEBODY MUST HAVE MOVED IT.
>> WELL, I GUESS I'LL JUST GET
MY MONEY BACK.
>> I'M SORRY SIR, WE ONLY OFFER
STORE CREDIT.
IT'S STORE POLICY.
>> OH, COME ON.
THAT'S [ BLEEP ].
>> SIR, I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO
CALM DOWN AND LOWER YOUR VOICE.
>> LOWER MY VOICE.
YOU'RE TRYING TO RIP ME OFF AND
I'M GETTING UPSET.
>> OKAY, SECURITY.
>> AND YOU WON'T LIKE ME WHEN
I'M UPSET.
>> WHAT'S THE PROBLEM HERE.
WHAT THE HELL?
LET GO OF ME.
>> AIN'T NOBODY EVEN TOUCHING
YOU.
>> I WANT MY MONEY BACK RIGHT
NOW.
>> WHILE WORKING AT HIS LAB
LOCATED ABOVE A TORREY BIRCH,
DR. BRUCE BANNER WAS HIT WITH
GAMMA RADIATION IN A FAILED
EXPERIMENT CAUSING HIM TO
TRANSFORM INTO AN EMBOLDENED
WHITE LADY WHENEVER HE IS
PROVOKED.
HE IS THE IMPOSSIBLE HULK.
>> I TOLD YOU SIR, THE STORE
POLICY IS --
>> YOU'RE BEING AGGRESSIVE.
I'M CALLING THE POLICE.
>> FOR WHAT?
>> 911, WHAT'S YOUR EMERGENCY.
>> YES, HELLO, YES.
I'D LIKE TO REPORT AN ACTIVE
AGGRESSION.
>> WE ARE LITERALLY JUST
STANDING HERE.
>> THEY ARE CROWDING ME, I CAN'T
BREATHE.
>> SIR, JUST TAKE YOUR MONEY
BACK.
IT'S FINE.
>> NO, DO NOT ARREST ME, DO NOT
TRY TO SILENCE ME.
>> OH, MAN.
THIS DUDE IS IMPOSSIBLE.
>> WHAT JUST HAPPENED?
>> WHAT?
>> CAN YOU PLEASE TURN THE MUSIC
DOWN?
I'M TRYING TO SLEEP.
>> YOU ARE FOREVER COMPLAINING.
WHY DON'T YOU JUST MOVE?
>> LOOK, I DON'T WANT TO ARGUE.
I'M ASKING YOU TO TURN THE MUSIC
DOWN OR ELSE.
>> OR ELSE WHAT?
>> OR ELSE I'M GOING TO GET
UPSET.
>> GET UPSET THEN.
WHAT'S UP?
>> LET GO OF MY ARM.
>> AIN'T NOBODY TOUCHING YOUR
ARM.
>> WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
I NEED EVERYONE'S NAME IN THERE.
>> DUDE, CALM DOWN.
>> I NEED YOUR MANAGER NOW.
>> THIS IS AN APARTMENT.
>> CALM DOWN.
>> YOU WILL NOT GET AWAY WITH
THIS.
>> 911, WHAT'S YOUR EMERGENCY?
>> YES, I'M BEING AGGRESSED
RIGHT NOW.
>> AGGRESSED?
WHAT IS THAT?
>> AND I CAN'T BREATHE, AND I'M
>> HEY, YOU OKAY, BRO?
>> FINE, I THINK I NEED A FROYO.
>> A FROYO?
>> NEXT TIME ON THE IMPOSSIBLE
HULK --
>> DAMNIT.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHY I'M STOPPING
YOU?
>> BECAUSE YOU'RE AN AGGRESSIVE
[ BLEEP ] -- I'M FILMING YOU FP
DRIVE SAFE.
♪♪♪